hey there welcome to conan o'brien's
different why are you laughing
why why are you laughing i don't know
your voice always gets to a point
because can i say something what happens
i think i know what you're going to say
when i'm just talking in the moment i'm
myself yeah but whenever you guys say
now it's time to start the podcast
i get in my head and i go what do i do i
want matt to do an impression because
i think he he knows okay so tell me
we're going to start the podcast okay
you're conan now and i'll be uh i'll be
matt gurley and just put down my banjo
and my uh antique felt hat
and my best truman doll um here we go
put that over there and then uh conan
you should probably start the podcast
now
silence silence
i do say why do i say murderer all the
time
all right so then okay come on come on
then you take like i'd say
30 seconds and you just go quiet and
still like you're meditating
and then you finally come out of it and
go eight registers deeper than your
normal voice
hello there welcome to
conan bryan he's a friend is it that bad
is it that bad
i'm not done yet oh the podcast where i
uh icon people into being my friend and
then you emerge into yourself
because it takes me yeah it takes me a
couple of
it takes i know i know it's not bad
about it now it's this moment of time no
i think it's
that 30 seconds you take to think about
it where you go into broadcaster mode
when you just gotta be old conezio b
ryan and get out there
but you're right i get into my head and
i think what is this we're doing now and
then i look and there's this giant
microphone in my face
and suddenly i feel like i'm supposed to
be professional and i go
hey conan o'brien immediately i know i'm
not being my authentic self
and then sona says something that
enrages me and i say murderer silence
silence yes and then suddenly we're back
uh to this normal voice let's try it if
you don't think about it one two three
go hey
conan o'brien here if conor bryant needs
a friend we're seeing a lot of traffic
downtown on the 405.
if you're gonna merge with the 101 make
sure you stay on the left lane we're
gonna
check in now with scotty joe scotty joe
what's going on
hey scotty joe here i got my puppet mr
crinkles well we'll check back in with
you guys later scotty joe mr griggles
you're listening to cob in the chill to
chill chums
you know if we go from the podcast into
that kind of radio that would be
so fantastic you know it would be kind
of retro
vintage it might just be yeah yeah would
it be cool again and
and you'd have to talk about guys that
are hot sauna yeah
i'm doing yeah you're doing some guys
doing some guy
and he's hot yeah tell us all about it
yeah tell us all about it
yeah we did it you just you're doing it
whoa
okay that's the most asexual
sexual conversation i've ever heard in
my life i met a guy he's hot we're doing
it and then we did it and then it was
done
yeah and then it was a done thing that
had been done
so one time it's time for sex reminisces
on the seventh yeah all right quick
update if you're trying to get to the
134
just be aware there's been a large
melted cheddar cheese spill
all over the highway they're rushing
beans to that site immediately to mix
them in with the cheese
and uh mike chopper is now descending
losing altitude quickly
i forgot to guess it up beforehand this
is my final broadcast
um yeah you're in the helicopter i mean
the guy in the helicopter doing this
report yeah yeah
you're in studio okay i have crashed i
am now in my admired in cheese
cheese on the 134 i have to tell you
it's kind of a sharp it's a sharp
cheddar
i believe from the taste of it wait a
minute that's my blood um
seven minutes after the hour time for
another sex remembrance from
sona back to you with another sex
remembers oh and make sure you put in
some helicopter noises behind me
gourley yeah later on
you do it in editing you don't you don't
have to do it now i don't think ah man
this is all
live we're going live you're right i'll
do it chopper chopper championship
oh no it's time for another edition of
sound
effects theater the theater chopper
chopper chopper oh no we're going down
descend crash uh
listen that was a terrible opening oh
stupid
i'm i am going to from now on yeah from
now on i'm just going to launch right
into it hey conan o'brien and you're
going to hear that other guy
oh who's that other guy i don't know you
either i don't know who any of these
guys are
i don't know just do what you do i
didn't mean to make you all
self-conscious about it it's just
it does you do like it's it's silent and
all of a sudden you're like
hi there yeah you know you know it's so
funny at home
uh if i say something my wife doesn't
like just she'll say like wait what did
you say i'll say don't worry about him
he's just crazy i know and she'll say
worry about who and i go
you know conan just being that way and
she'll say wait you're conan and i'll go
no and it totally gets me out of it
every time that's pretty good yeah i'll
be like yeah i say
so i'll be talking to her so you be liza
and i'll just say something like oh well
could we eat sooner
what can we eat soon you know what don't
don't worry about him
he's just you know what he is he's
narcissist
and it's all about him and his show and
his podcast and just
just walk away from him because you know
what you're better than him
and she's like who are we talking about
well yeah who are you talking about
trust me
conan's just a dick sometimes but you
know what and then i
become her confidant who's the good guy
who's allying with her against conan
okay it's fantastic
that's pretty brilliant try it it's very
healthy when my children look at it and
then they leave the room and they just
cry
okay that makes sense